uh joined Now by Dai Babu who is a
former Chief superintendent with the
Metropolitan Police hi it's good to see
you are our police officers to PC do you
think that's never been my experience I
think um there's no evidence of that
police officers do an incredibly tough
job you see police officers having to
deal with fights disordering Town
they're doing lots of Investigations I
think the idea that the police are doing
PC and that's why they're they're not
actually getting involved and doing the
kind of Investigations that people want
us to do is more about the fact that
we've had austerity we've had a huge
reduction in policing and we've now got
a very inexperienced police force
because of that reduction in pleasing I
did make that point actually to the Home
Secretary something like 40 of police
officers on the streets now and
otherwise
um have got less than five years
experience she didn't really take that
on board well I think hey that's the
most important point it's a hugely
inexperienced organization I mean I I'll
give you a personal example I um I was
at a friend's house there was a burglary
next door went outside and the house I
was in had CCTV cameras and there's some
new police officers outside and I should
have spoke to him and said look we've
got CCTV you know into the interpersonal
skills were very very poor they were a
little bit nervous
um and they never came back to check the
CCTV and I just think you know it just
shows that that whole lack of
um experience is just you know you
interacting if somebody's offering you
some evidence you know at least have the
characters to say actually we won't
require it you know but there was none
of that
how do we fix that
this is a problem that's been going on
for decades uh you you you do this huge
cut back in policing when crime goes
down crime goes up and then you end up
having to recruit lots of police
officers I think we need to have some
degree of stability in policing I feel
very very sorry for my colleagues who
are doing a on the in the main doing a
good job but are struggling because
they've got a hugely inexperienced group
of individuals who have joined the
organization and then have to learn on
the job there's no alternative to
learning on the job
like that so many of our Police Services
appear to be in special measures not
just the met but greater Manchester
Cleveland gloucestershire Staffordshire
Wiltshire
well I'm glad you've said all of those
okay because the danger is sometimes we
just focus on the on the met you know
this is a problem across all of the
country and if you look at greater
Manchester please there's similar
similar kind of issues that people have
been talking about
um very openly about the Met are present
in somewhere like greater Manchester
another big Falls to make it right
though does it no absolutely not but I
think we need to understand that this is
if we just focus on one force we do
ourselves a huge disservice we need to
be looking at the entirety of the police
service and what about the fact that um
to look at officers who have behaved
inappropriately
well the one of the biggest challenges
that the police has is the lack of trust
at the moment tell me and then there's a
there's a great Dutch saying that talks
about Trust walking towards you and
disappearing on the back of a horseback
and I think we're in that situation with
the police you know trust trustees are
really really important commodity and
because trust has gone it's never been
lower behind you as we're talking about
it I mean when you have somebody like
him and his absolutely
Behavior It's tricky to come back from
that absolutely I mean David Carrick
should never have been allowed in the
police it never and actually and he was
then given the authority to carry
firearms so somebody had decided Well
not just one person but several people
had decided that despite his history he
was going to be given additional vetting
get through that additional vetting and
have a firearm now I've I've turned
people down for because I've been
involved in domestic abuse instances and
I said that you're not appropriate to
carry a farm now somebody you had a
sergeant who's who said an inspector
you've had a very senior officer who has
agreed for this individual to carry a
farm despite all the evidence we have so
that's a difficulties we trust at the
moment you know and so so in in an
answer to your point I think you really
need to make sure that you invest
resources in that and if that means
sometimes taking resources elsewhere to
put into investigating police officers I
think that has to be done I see it as a
short-term measure not a long-term
measure okay we must leave it now it's
good to talk to you thanks so much to do
for joining us on the program foreign